day nine of the invasion we're going to
take a look at the situation in the
south of ukraine the most significant
development the bombing of the nuclear
power station at zaparizo michael clark
our defense analyst uh your best
analysis of of how that happened
uh i think the strategic explanation
might be that president putin wanted to
frighten everybody i think the real
explanation it was probably actually uh
strategic stupidity on the part of local
forces it usually turns out to be that
in this sort of case that is worrying
given that we've got a second power
station perhaps we should be aware of
close to russian forces yeah and the
whole front is now moving towards the
west so we're thinking about what
happens next uh in odessa uh and around
the uh that part of the black sea coast
of uh ukraine so let's take a look at
that let's zoom in on this area around
odessa significant at the moment no red
lines means no russian control at the
moment but how is that going to play out
and tell us also about uh chona mosque
the uh
the commercial port yeah so desert is
the historic port chauner mosque is the
commercial port existed since the 1950s
since uh uh then those two ports account
for about 70 percent of all of the black
sea trade of ukraine if they're taken by
the russians which one assumes
eventually they will be
then that's pretty bad news for
ukraine's economy and you expect the
forces to move towards odessa it looks
as if they will um they're fighting at
the moment mikolaiv uh they've the
russians have been repelled once at
mikolive uh in the last 24 hours but i'm
sure that they will eventually have to
give ground there at some point and
there are assets at sea as part of this
operation we think yes the russians have
got assault ships at sea they've got a
maritime force so one would expect that
when the ground troops are ready to
attack odessa that the troops at sea
will probably join them in a a maritime
assault let's uh look quickly at the
battle for kiev we have reports today
earlier today of renewed hostilities
hostimal explain uh the significance
strategically of this airfield yes the
russians tried to take hostile airfield
um in the early stage of the conflict
with an airborne assault and it didn't
work they got beaten back
hostile is a really important strategic
asset because if you hold hostile
airfield you can bring troops into it
much more easily than bringing them by
road and you can use hostile airfield to
attack kiev itself from the air so both
for defence and the attack on kiev
hostimal airfield is a very important
strategic asset
thank you michael so as we go into the
second weekend of the invasion the fate
of key strategic assets around kiev
still up in the air and a long haul
ahead for both the russian invading
force and perhaps more importantly those
on the ground in ukraine